Suzanne
[Musique]
dommage Rinaldi
m'a abandonné
coeur ta malédiction rauque mal ton
la larme de R m'emmène dans les profondeurs
sous le fond où je jette
sueva et donc je ne le fais pas
dis que tu as
pourquoi la vie est une blessure
Absurde et tout est si éphémère que c'est
un curda juste moi
confession Dis-moi que tu es avec
dis-moi ton échec, tu ne vois pas la honte que ça me fait
ça fait mal et parle-moi
simplement de cet amour absent après
un fragment de
J'oublie, je sais que ça te fait mal, je sais que
Je t'ai blessé en pleurant mon sermon
Il a vu mais c'est le vieil amour que tu laves
León et cherche une liqueur qui
étourdit la courbe qui à la fin termine le
fonction exécutant un
rideau à
[Musique]
coeur un peu
Je me souviens et sans
le savon dégouline de toi
Je refais ta liqueur et garde le troupeau
du pied gauche en renversant le dernier
Curda ferme-le pour moi
fenêtre qui brûle le soleil, c'est lent
escargot
rêve Ne vois-tu pas que je viens d'un pays qui
est oublié
sipr après le
[Musique]
Dis-moi ta phrase, dis-moi ton échec
Tu ne vois pas la douleur qui m'a blessé et tu ne me parles pas
simplement de cet amour absent que tu donneras
un fragment de
J'oublie que je sais ce qui t'a blessé
agitant mon sermon
du vin mais c'est le vieil amour qui tremble
Je vais à León et je cherche une liqueur qui
La courbe dure jusqu'à la fin
fonction exécutant un
rideau à
coeur
[Musique]
Oh